As we said, the key idea is we're
going to use this model of motion to
make these predictions.
And there are two goals, right?
Goal number one is that we can
do less work because of this.
Because we have some idea of where the
object is going to be we can restrict
our search.
Goal number two is we should be able to
actually improve our estimates because
we're using both predictions based
upon dynamics and our measurements.
Now, to do this,
we're going to make certain assumptions.
Okay?
And the assumptions basically come down
to the notion that this is some
form of continuous motion.
We're going to assume that
objects don't disappear and
reappear instantly somewhere else.
For those of you child psychology,
that's a whole Piaget thing.
Kids don't come to that belief until I
don't know, it's like year and a half or
something like that.
So like kids who are, are really little,
if you take a toy truck and you've got
a screen here, and you put the toy
truck behind the screen, and then you
lift up the screen and the truck's not
there anymore, they're not surprised.
Things disappear in their universe all
the time, or it becomes a, a carrot.
They're not surprised either.
Then all of the sudden they get to
a certain age where the truck comes,
if you pick it up and
it's a carrot, they're like whoa.
All right?
And
that requires a certain
change in the mental model.
Okay I don't know why I mentioned that.
It's just really cool.
It's true by the way, not that Piaget is
all true but that's true about children.
Anyway so we're going to make our
assumption in our tracking that,
that things don't just appear and
disappear.
We're also making an assumption that
the camera doesn't move instantaneously.
You know,
because that would be the same thing.
All right, if I instantly went from
here to here, right, big change,
things will have violated my
apparent continuous motion.
So that's basically that there's
this gradual change imposed between
the camera and the scene and the object.